from 6 years old all I wanted was to be
famous a lifetime two night documentary
event Showtime executive produced by
Wendy
Williams the boss is walking everybody
nobody can do it like Wendy no one
people love Wendy you are a star she was
in her living room every single day for
12 years yep I guess that'll do and
that's what people responded to her
authenticity and then at the peak of her
career
she was
gone are we ready yeah reading on you
all right and away we go love you Wy all
I know is how to be famous I really want
to be back on television you're going to
be back on TV that's easy my mom has
done a great job making it seem like
everything is okay always Wendy make
sure you look here one two three but in
reality there's something wrong going on
did you see a neurologist to find out if
I'm
crazy mhm oh my God no I can't do this I
can't do this I have to sit down again
she was put in front of a judge and
given a guardian that was when they took
her away from us I have no money and I'm
going to tell you something if it
happens to me it could happen to you as
her family we were all sitting on the
sidelines watching and she was crying
out for help did you drink this whole
thing today keep it there okay keep it
there my mom she always talks about how
she wants to work but I feel as though
she's worked
enough she has people around who are yes
people and allowing this to continue
this is all too much go drive I have no
idea where we are this doesn't look like
anything familiar I think she's losing
memory have you guys noticed that how
dare him I control me I weigh one
38 anybody could look at her and tell
this is not just alcohol there's
something more going
on I miss my family I'll be
here no matter how many times somebody
may fall down you got to lift them back
up we all make choices in life we all go
through our
challenges she's still a person how you
doing that's my sister there have been
random people around you stealing money
from me getting money whatever the case
may be enough can you tell me where your
sister is no I don't know the exact
location of where she is I feel like the
guardian has not done a good job of
protecting my mom my life my life right
now she's weak and vulnerable and she
needs to be around people who aren't
going to take advantage of that I have
no friends you know how many people come
out to support you you know how many
people love you no I don't everything is
going to be bu I know
I think that the guardianship system is
broken we are her family and you tell me
that I'm not capable of taking care of
my sister what would you do what should
I
do I love being
famous but family everything so good to
see you again Dad it's good to see you
Bab everything where is Wendy Williams a
two night documentary event Premier
Saturday February 24th at 8 only on life
time